come on stand a little closer
[Music]
what's up guys so today's episode we're
gonna be what this is weird
why is it weird cuz you're never in the
beginning of videos that's true yeah you
can't just switch it off like that on us
right just cuz it's Thanksgiving if you
change up for Thursday routine no jelena
here is gonna try to catch all the red
lights so we could pull up next to cars
I'm gonna somehow get their attention
and once I get their attention I'm gonna
tell them if you can say anything to
100,000 people what would it be 100,000
people are you guys he looks like a nice
guy yeah the guy in Hawaii
yes right here it's not something hey
you think it's interview you say
anything 200,000 people what would it be
to a hundred thousand people yeah that's
a lot of pressure I don't know
rock on the world
to each other understand empathy
and diversity makes us stronger adults
who stopped you to kids for two
generations with the
we pay for the tree just keep swimming
why are all you guys here
[Music]
hello moon DL right twist it up don't
get it twisted there's more meaning so I
would tell me there was more meaning now
tell them that we're not as smart as we
think we are we need to for ourselves
and we need to
the simple [ __ ] there's a million
differences that we have so we need to
focus on what we have in common
watch out are you trying to drive your
car through the fire because your car
will choke too and you will burn
a lot of people that's the news too but
I'll tell you that your car is going to
choke out too when you drive
love each other
love each other love each other people
a very unique it's probably like
right good idea in general I don't know
em hi how are you be cool yeah I'm the
way to get ready go crawl the lady
before you said find a way to get rid of
Trump polarize the game II 2020 I love
United States where are you from Jordan
how's your day going leave it down in
the comments below have a nice day
live your life to the fullest
are you having a good day yeah please
let's get back from
[Music]
and let anybody stop you tell you
wouldn't sugar expecting you should
remember that a lot of what people say
have to do with themselves and not
necessarily you so I guess keep that in
mind when dealing with other people and
taking things personal that it's not
always people out to get you that you
should just try to be empathetic and put
yourself in other people's shoes and try
to learn lessons from other people that
way well enjoy life because life is very
short and in your realties and big
[Music]
use me
can I see a quick question on camera
okay I'm just so bad okay Carson back
here you did not really good not that
one that boys what you hole was jabal
what you do cops is filmed on location
with a bundle of enforcement